GUEST SPEAKER: Dear
Governor, as you
know, we're currently
facing a controversy
around the funding for cleanup
of a highly polluted Superfund
site.
Before delving
into some details,
I wanted to divide my
talk into three parts.
First, I'll walk you
through why this has become
a controversial topic today.
Secondly, I'll walk
you through how
you can apply
cost-benefit analysis
in this particular case.
And finally, I'll close
with some observations
around possible gaps
and recommendations
on how to move forward.
So first some background.
A decade ago some abandoned
underground storage tanks
from a former foundry leaked
into neighboring wetlands.
Given that the company
had gone out of business,
it was impossible to
hold them to account
for the cost of the cleanup.
As a result, we put in $3
million to cap the site
and sequester the
polluted water and soil.
Today this issues resurfaced
because the city wants
to build a new mall on
the site and has requested
that the state government fund
the construction of a road that
would link this area
near an interstate.
This sparked debate
around who should
fund the cleanup, which is
estimated to cost $35 million.
The local government argues
that the economic benefits
of the mall on this site will be
widespread so the state should
cover these costs.
However, the
transportation agency
believes that the developers
should cover these costs given
that they will gain much
of the economic benefits.
To develop a position, you asked
me to work on a cost benefit
analysis, and I'll walk
you through the process
of this analysis.
As you know the purpose
of a cost benefit analysis
is to determine whether
the social benefits exceed
the social costs.
The benefits are an increase
in the human environmental
well-being, while the
costs are the reductions
in this well-being.
To sum the benefits, we would
calculate the willingness
to pay for benefits
or accept compensation
for any losses that might occur.
We also determine the
standing, in other words,
the stakeholders whose costs and
benefits are to be considered,
and the time over which
these costs and benefits are
to be counted and
discounted over time.
Finally, to compare
the costs and benefits,
we use that present value.
In other words, the discount
of these values over time.
And then that present
value is important
because it helps us
rank our options.
And we should only
consider implementing
those that have a positive
net present value.
For this particular
case here are
some of the most
important direct
and indirect costs and benefits
that we could focus on.
Some of the potential costs
of development of this mall
would be the actual
cleanup of the site
and the ongoing monitoring of
any lingering contamination,
certifying compliance
and authorizing
sites for redevelopment,
building, maintaining a road
or necessary structures such
as bridges or parking lots,
loss of revenue of existing
local and state businesses,
increased traffic, as well
as air and noise pollution
in the area and any resulting
shifts in demographics
of these areas.
Some potential benefits
could be economic activity
and generation of business
revenues, employments, wages,
and benefits that can affect
household income, which
in turn can propel the economy,
and state and local taxes
can increase revenue
for the government.
It's important to note
that many of these issues
can be seen as either
cost or benefits
depending on different
stakeholders point of view.
For example, a
large new mall could
increase the property value
in some surrounding areas
and decrease it in others.
As far as time
frame, it would be
important to capture
each phase involved
from the cleanup of the
development construction
to its functioning
in the long-term,
so we can project the potential
long-term costs and benefits.
Ideally, a lot of
psychoanalysis that
captures the impacts of
the mall from construction
to deconstruction
would be carried out.
Regarding the
geographic scope, it's
key to include in the
study the actual site
plus a certain
radius of surrounding
areas and neighboring towns
to ensure that cost benefit
analysis gains the full picture
of the impacts of the project.
Each cost benefit would
require a different scope
depending on the impact
and how far it would
reach the surrounding areas.
Consultation with
local stakeholders
can be helpful in
determining the scope.
Finally, regarding the question
of inevitable distribution
of costs and benefits.
We may give higher
weight of cost benefit
for particular stakeholders
who may experience the impacts
at different rates due
to particular situations
or locations such as
indigenous peoples
with cultural and physical
survival may be at stake.
Those who are negatively
affected by it
would carry higher
costs, and therefore that
should be factored in.
To wrap up, I just wanted to
offer some recommendations
and closing thoughts.
One, issues that
we're discussing,
two, scenarios
keeping the site as is
or conducting cleanup for a
new development such as a mall.
To make an informed decision and
given that environmental groups
claim that there have
been long-term health
effects experienced by
water users in the area,
it would be key to carry out
environmental health risk
analysis of the
current site, so we
know what we're comparing the
action of redevelopment to.
In this case, non-monetary
costs and benefits
should be given a score so
that the two options of action
and non-action can be compared.
Moreover, I would also encourage
us to consider other options
aside from the
construction of a mall
as a form of redevelopment.
It would be
important to consider
other alternatives
that might generate
higher benefit at a lower cost.
Taking these steps and
conducting a cost benefit
analysis will give us a
more comprehensive picture
of the situation and fill
in some important gaps
of information that
we currently face
to make an informed decision.
A well done cost
benefit analysis
will help us determine
which course of action,
as well as how much each party
should contribute to make
this plan actually happen.
Thank you.